quand on regarde les propos de la jeune
personne les auraient riva aussi fort
également donc on est passé sans
transition de l'homme n'ont aucune
excuse à l'homme à tous les la femme à
tous les droits alors c'est pas bien
raquel garrido déjà vous quand vous avez
réagi quand vous avez vu que maty de
panneaux avaient été traités de
poissonnière à la santé j'étais ulcérée
parce que moi qui suis une militante de
longue date et une femme qui prend la
parole on va dire d'une façon un peu
opiniâtre oui ça soit je vous le
confirme et j'ai l'habitude j'ai
l'habitude de recevoir ce genre de coup
en dessous de la ceinture
que dira-t-il pas nous à la pâleur de se
laisser faire quand même ses actes et
c'est peut-être pour ça d'ailleurs qu'à
des hommes voilà il ya des hommes qui se
sentent menacés par les femmes qui sont
voilà qui ont de la verve qui se laisse
pas faire il ya des hommes qui ne
l'acceptent pas et du coup il n'arrive
pas à retenir leur langue et dans cette
configuration de l'assemblée nationale
qu' une configuration très spécial où
effectivement la liberté de parole est
forte ou historiquement je m'aime je
sais pas si vous le savez mais il ya une
immunité de la parole dans l'hémicycle
c'est à dire qu' on ne peut pas
poursuivre un parlementaire pour ce que
pour les mots qu'il a prononcés dans les
mythiques parce qu'on veut que nous
parlementaires disent tous qu'ils
pensent alors que jean veil
s'autocensurent mais du coup ça veut
dire que l'assemblée nationale elle même
doit faire la police vu que la police je
dire mettre en place des règles parce
que la société peuvent affaire la
justice ne peut pas le faire il ya une
immunité donc la règle le l'assemblée
doit décider qu'est ce qui est de
l'ordre de cette liberté de ton et
qu'est ce qu'il n'est pas et moi alors
c'est ma position je pense qu'il ya une
limite c'est voilà tout ce qui est
d'ordre sexistes ou racistes
alors je pense qu'en 2021 c'est une
limite qu'on peut hacker tous mettre en
place et est d'accord pour dire qu'on
n'a pas fait un peu trop matip panneaux
pour faire parler d'elle aussi aisée que
je vais me servir de ça pour faire
parler de moi pour faire un buzz et pour
que derrière connaissons que commence la
connaissez pas votre panneau grata quand
je la connais